Part B on what open intervals contained
in negative three is less than X is less
than four is the graph of F both concave
down and decreasing give a reason for
your answer
all right so f is needs to be both
concave down and decreasing so f concave
down concave down that's going to be
true if and only if the second
derivative of F is less than zero which
is true if and only if F prime is
decreasing F prime is decreasing so
that's how we can tell when F is concave
down and I wanted I want to see what do
I need to observe on F prime because
that's the graph they gave us all right
now for F to be decreasing F is going to
be decreasing if and only if what you're
decreasing when you have a negative
slope if your rate of change is negative
so that's true if and only if F prime of
X is less than zero so both true both
true when F prime of x is less than zero
and decreasing and let me write and F
prime is decreasing and F prime
decreasing so let's see if we can
identify that where let's go back to our
graph and see when is f prime of X less
than zero and decreasing so if we look
at less than zero let me highlight this
in a so less than zero I'm highlighting
it in magenta right over here this is
all the places where we are less than
zero in magenta and now of that where
are we decreasing well we are decreasing
over this interval right over here so
that would be negative 2 is less than X
which is less than negative one so
that's we're decreasing of the places
where we are negative I'm taking the
subset of where we are negative to think
about well where are we decreasing we're
decreasing right there and we're also
decreasing or also decreasing right over
there
so that is one is less than X which is
less than three now we are decreasing
before x equals negative two over here
but we're not less than zero there so
I'm not going to include that and so we
have our intervals so our open intervals
so we have both true when for when these
two things are true and so this happens
this happens when negative 2 is less
than X is less than negative 1 or 1 is
less than X is less than 3 so those are
our two open intervals this one and that
one